table tennis is more commonly known as
pingpong folding table tennis tables are
popular in homes and kept Outdoors
because they can be closed up and rolled
out of the way these tables can also
fold down on just one side allowing for
solo
play this high-end outdoor table tennis
table has an aluminum bottom that
prevents the tabletop called the plate
from warping or splitting due to
expansion and contraction a press stamps
cups into a sheet of aluminum this
pattern creates nearly equal areas both
in contact and out of contact with the
rest of the plate layers providing
flexibility to withstand temperature
related movement each table needs two
embossed aluminum sheets one for each
half of the
plate a technician assembles frames for
the plate halves out of square extruded
aluminum tubes cut to the lengths and
widths of the plate half
perimeter an automated milling machine
makes miter cuts which allow the tubes
to be made into
rectangles then the technician moves the
frames onto a rotating
[Music]
fixture and welds the corners
together
[Music]
the frames are inserted into a brushing
machine inside wire brush rollers allow
the aluminum surface to become rough
this helps the components to adhere to
one
another another technician places the
embossed aluminum sheet into a
rectangular assembly
jig
and adds the brush aluminum
[Music]
frame a conveyor transfers The Jig to
the next
station then The Jig connects with an 8
mm thick sheet of particle board made of
wood chips and glue the board is coated
with a heat activated adhesive film on
both
sides at the next station an aluminum
sheet is placed on top of the particle
board this step completes the plate
component
[Music]
assembly next the conveyor loads The Jig
into a
press once 12 jigs have been loaded onto
the press it Heats to 239° F and
compresses them for about 10 minutes
this process activates the adhesive and
bonds the components of each plate into
a single unit one framed plate half
[Music]
each plate half goes through an
automated milling
[Music]
machine the machine trims any excess
material from all four sides to ensure
the table won't have any sharp
[Music]
edges
the plate half goes through a paint
machine then into an oven the process
repeats applying a second coat of paint
and a UV resistant clear
coat a machine applies paint through a
screen stencil printing the lines that
Mark the boundaries of the playing
[Music]
surface after the paint is dried in an
oven a team play places the finished
plate half in a cardboard box and
attaches folding legs to the
base the factory Mills the legs in house
out of high tensil steel then finishes
them in baked on
paint the net along with several
components are packed and made inhouse
which the consumer later assembles to
the table components include the net
posts side panels Wheels wheel brakes
and the ball return box
finally the plate half is transferred to
an automated system which completes the
packaging many pingpong tables on the
market require the net to be removed
every time you fold the table the design
of this table enables the net to remain
in place whether the table is folded for
storage or has one or both sides open
for
playing less setup time means more time
to
[Music]
play
plastic model kits were developed before
World War II when people became
interested in seeing machines in small
scale replication today plastic model
kits continue to offer building
opportunities to hobbyists who love the
challenge of putting little pieces
together with a plastic model kit a
colossal ocean liner can be replicated
in small scale built with nearly 2,000
pieces assembly is all about the details
each model kit starts with extensive
research and design a process that can
take up to a year to complete and cost
up to
$100,000 using the computer design a set
of Steel molds is made for every piece
of the
kit tools carve into steel chunks to
make the
molds Precision work done entirely by
Machinery installed and large dies the
molds are linked by channels melted
plastic will flow through the channels
to fill the molds clear polystyrene is
used for transparent
components the melted polystyrene is
pumped under high pressure into the
molds once the plastic hardens a pusher
ejects the
parts the connected kit parts are known
as a
tree the opaque polystyrene pellets are
used to form the other kit parts and are
molded
separately the scale of the parts is 1
to 24 which means the model will be 124
the size of the original since the
manufacturing is automated the risk of
contamination is
reduced next the tree is put through a
technical analysis test the technician
photographs the tree and Compares it to
an image already fit to scale if some
parts haven't taken shape or if they're
only partially formed more pressure may
be needed to ensure that the poly stying
flows into all the mold
cavities a technician Compares a
randomly selected tree to the design and
verifies that no parts are poorly formed
or missing once the confirmation is
obtained the technician slides the model
kit Parts into a clear plastic
sleeve before it's ready for retail the
kit needs a set of Illustrated
instructions the designer deconstructs
the model and then reconstructs it on
his computer as he draws up the
instructions with the instruction manual
complete a team packs all the components
of the model kit in a
box one of each of the kit trees is
placed in each
box the kit also includes decals and
large separately molded Parts like the
ocean liner
Hall a technician closes the
box as it moves down a conveyor a laser
prints the date of production and the
batch number on the
side then the box is wrapped in plastic
and the ends are sealed with heat
guns a year of planning has gone into
making the plastic mold
kit but it took less than 10 minutes to
mold the kit parts and package
them
building the model will take 10 to 12
hours the factory does the test build on
each model to confirm that it comes
together as
planned this is the iconic constellation
aircraft a world war2 military transport
plane that was later converted to a
commercial
airliner assembling a plastic model kit
can be a great learning experience for
the
Builder decals mimic the idea
information on the outside of the
original
aircraft these decals have been
pre-treated with
adhesive soaking the decals in water
activates
them the assembler brushes more water
onto the designed spots on the
model and applies the decals to the
dampened spots as the glue dries they
adere to each
other the plastic models can also be
painted before the decals are applied
for a refined and clean look that really
comes
together